how does one even try to describe the
world the fairies well he's in the case
of John Crowley it was over 500 pages
worth to try and do it hey there
everybody patreon sponsored review and
it's a book a little while since I've
been commissioned on one of those or
actually it's been a little while since
I've been working on reading this I've
been working on this one for a while
this is a a rather thick book and the
way that it is written makes for slow
going that is not necessarily the
criticism you might be thinking I will
explain what I get there but first let
me explain what this thing is a little
bit or at least attempt to so the book
is called little big it was written in
the early 80s by a guy by the name of
John Crowley or Crowley I'm not sure how
was Brian I'm going with Crowley and
this is both an author and a book I had
never heard of before I was commissioned
apparently this is considered by some to
be something of a of a lost sort of
fantasy masterpiece and it didn't get it
didn't do badly but it didn't get a ton
of recognition at the time it sort of
had a bit of a resurgence and more
recent time so it seems to be getting a
little bit more appreciation for what it
is it's a very unique book at least in
terms of anything that I've ever read
before so I need to try and decide how
I'm going to summarize it in a broad
sense before I start really digging into
my thoughts on it this book is a it's
not quite magical realism it kind of
straddles the line between magical
realism and low fantasy if you don't
know fantasy term fantasy genre
terminology high fantasy is when you're
dealing with a completely originally
created world like say you know your
middle-earth Shore Lord of the Rings
low fantasy is when you're dealing with
more or less the real world with fantasy
elements in it ie your Harry Potter's
your Dresden Files and then magical
realism is a setting where magic exists
but it's not treated like anything
exceptional it's just it's just there
and it did it's usually in a very
incredibly low-key way this is kind of
rides the line between magical realism
and low fantasy and it as I said it's a
multi-generational story focusing on the
members of the Drinkwater family both
the biological and the ones who marry
and we actually start with a character
named smokey who is going to Wed a woman
named Alice referred to as daily Alice
and that sort of are in his first
learning about this family and the place
where they live called Edgewood and that
home and its history is sort of the way
in which the reader gets introduced to
all the concepts that are going on and
we learn about the family about its
interaction with the very complicated
and in many ways sort of nonlinear and
to humanize not particularly cohesive
world of fairies what happens to some
family members when they venture away
from Edgewood and live in a city there's
also some stuff going on on a grander
scale towards the end but I'll kind of
come back to that a little bit but it's
a difficult book to try and sum up and
you'll notice as far as the storyline
goes I've talked to pretty broad strokes
there's a couple of reasons for that the
first is it's a multi-generational story
so there are a lot of characters to deal
with there is no one central character
which honestly for me is something that
took a little getting used to because at
the front end of it
smokey is our lead-in and then it's you
know it kind of expands to him and daily
Alice ok daily Alice's sister Sophie you
know that you know their family we got
little background a history Mike okay
but then latter half of the book and we
start dealing with smokey and Alice's
kids and the and focusing so much on
them and not like as kids still have a
home like as adults living lives it it
really did feel like a bit of a jolt for
me I suspect that's kind of how
multi-generational stories tend to go
that's not a type of fiction I'm used to
reading so that threw me off a little
but I don't think that was any kind of
issue with the book but the main reason
why it's difficult to try and explain
and describe this book and also the
reason why it took me a very long time
to read it you know beyond even with the
page count you should have taken me is
the way in which it's written it is
written in what I can only think to
describe as borderline poetic dense
literary narrative so I kept coming
across in thinking the phrase this reads
like poetry but I really need to clarify
and explain that because it doesn't read
like poetry for the reasons people might
normally say that people have a tendency
to say that when something's written in
overly flowery language or really purple
prose or things like that and that's not
really the case here I'm not gonna say
there's none of that but when I say it
reads like poetry what I mean is if
you've ever read a poem that was
intending to convey any kind of story
you generally come away from that with a
sense of the events you know a happen to
be happening to see happen boy you come
away with much more strongly is a feel
of what happened maybe you couldn't
chart it out on a narrative break down
and pick apart the structure but you
know how you are left feeling about
what you know that occurred and that's
the way the narrative of this thing
comes across at the end of any given
section I oftentimes would realize that
not a lot had actually happened and I
wasn't entirely sure how well I could
have explained it if you'd asked me but
I still came away with very distinct
feelings
regardless very distinct impressions and
emotions being stirred and general vibe
off of the characters and the events
going on all of that is very much at the
forefront of it as a reading experience
and it took me a little while to get on
the wavelength of this book and also I
am gonna recommend soaps like peek
behind the curtain here um when I get
commissioned to do books I will make use
of audio book if I'm in a time crunch
but even on the occasions where I've
done that it was only for parts of the
book in question I try and do as much of
the reading from the actual text as I
can as I can find the time to do but
this is a case where spoiler I am gonna
have some reasons to recommend this book
depending on what your tastes are I'm
not gonna recommend the audiobook to
anybody all due respect to the man John
Crowley did the reading of it himself
and it doesn't work the the the way it's
written is so unusual that combined with
the fact that he's just not a great
reader of it to listen to the end the
whole thing turned me off and but but I
thankfully I did realize it was just
listening to him those throwing me off
not the actual book and when I basically
had to chuck this is why this took me so
long
I had to chuck the audio book in the bin
and not even use it to try and catch up
and make up for time for segments and
pretty much read the whole thing legit
which made me appreciate it
much much more in this particular case
and once you are in tune with the
narrative and you
get used to the idea of it it's not
actually necessary for me to go back and
reread the section because I feel like
I'm not entirely sure what happened as
long as you know what you feel about it
you're okay to keep moving forward and
it was a very interesting experience to
read because of that and like I said a
very unique one there are portions of it
that you know rang very true even like
gave me things to think about in
feelings that were that were quite deep
and the way it's broken down is is
interesting as well it's the the novel
is broken down into thinkit's but yeah I
know it's six books each book consisting
of four or five chapters and each
chapter being broken into named segments
which could last from anywhere from half
a page to ten pages so you know this
thing just breaks a lot of the standard
structure of what you'd expect aside
from the learning curve of getting a
handle on the writing style I do have a
couple of things that I do feel are more
legitimate criticisms of it more so than
just you need to get used to it
so the first is part of this just likely
has to do with the time in which it was
written like said early 80s but it is a
little bit male gaze at times not in a
especially creepy or overt way however
by the time it was done I was really
noticing how often the visible sexual
characteristics of female characters
were being remarked on versus the fact
that it was basically never mentioned
for the male characters and again it's
not like it's all the time but I I
really was noticing by the end is like
why there was no need to point that out
you know point out that somewhat
sexualized elements
of the character in that moment but you
did anyways so there's a little bit of
that going on and the other thing is
there are in the second half of the book
that takes place in a city as opposed to
this you know remote this remote
location of Edgewood there are some
there are a number of non-white
characters and a lot of them have
phonetically written accents which I'm
not sure I'm gonna make the argument
that doing that is an inherently bad
idea but I know for me as a reader it
can often put me off and in this case it
definitely did beyond that there's in
terms of the sexualized aspects and
there isn't a ton I wouldn't say this is
like an adults-only book but it is kind
of dealing with more mature themes of
family and how things connect and the
overall journey of one's life you know
things that I think younger readers
probably wouldn't wouldn't have the
background of the life experience to
properly appreciate even if they could
they could wrap around the language
there's there's a character named Oberon
well actually there's two characters
named Oberon but over on the elder see
what I mean by that by a big cast
multi-generational Oberon the elder is
also a character who made me slightly
uncomfortable not so much in that what
went on with him but it felt like the
book I I kind of needed the narrative to
judge him a bit more than does so as
quickly as I can put it he basically
engages in fairy photography and around
that time period if you know about the
like the fairy photographs craze of it
was like the nineteen twenties ish kind
of time period and photos from people
like Lewis Carroll you know of young
children with fairies well Oberon the
elder did that
he his way of going about that while it
is presented as innocently as it can be
it is uncomfortably sexual as he's
photographing these children and I'm not
gonna say that that like that's okay for
the character to be that way I don't
know how I feel about that I will say
though it made me very uncomfortable
that it it read to me like the narrative
and the story thought that this was not
a big deal
simply because he never laid a hand on
the girls and the children involved
which is good um that like if that
happened I might have had to close the
book and gotten in touch with the person
who commissioned it said I can't finish
this but I kind of needed the book I
needed somebody a character or a general
sense from the narrative that like yeah
he doesn't get why this is not right but
it's not right let's so the fact that
that didn't have him made me slightly
uncomfortable thankfully though it's his
section I'm what I'm talking about is a
very it's a it's like I don't know this
much of the book it's not a lot but I'd
be remiss if I didn't mention it the
thing is the way in which it's written
ISM for me a much bigger cell than the
actual story although the way in which
it layers and explores the idea of
fairies and particularly the ways in
which the world of the fairies overlaps
with this family I find really
interesting and it especially kind of
gels with me in a certain way because
this family that basically has to take a
lot on faith because they have they are
not fully going to understand what is
going on with this other realm and this
other world and these other beings they
can try and some of them even think that
they will have some revelation and they
will understand but they're not going to
they never will but they're still
intertwined in all of this they have a
role in a story and
No and this family knows they have a
role in the story but some of them think
it's a role that is something other than
what it is some of them flat-out don't
know what their role is at all
some of them know but that knowing comes
with realizing that they're just a very
small part of something and that sort of
almost bordering on existentialism but
like not tipping over into the more
depressing elements that that tends to
lend I found to be really fascinating in
terms of the way it connected the
characters to each other into this more
magical realm it was it was just
presented really well it and like I said
it's incredibly well written and it's
the kind of thing that if for as long as
it took me to read I could see myself
reading again which I don't say about
many books but I'm gonna add the caveat
I suspect I would probably only read the
first half of it again
it's not that the second half is bad
this is gonna sound like a weird
criticism the second habit where the
plot happens and the book is that it's
best in at its most for like less
cliched term magical in the first half
as you're just getting to know what
little bits that you will ever
understand about these connections in
these worlds and these people and this
house with God the way Edgewood is
described as incredible and getting to
know that is really what grabbed me and
then in the latter half actual story
kicks in even including a characters who
might arguably be villains and I
remember getting to the point where
these characters get introduced and
thinking what are you even doing here
this story doesn't need villains this
story doesn't need a bigger conflict
like what what is this why is this even
here and it doesn't derail things it
just did not feel like a natural
progression of what had been going on
it just it felt it felt like a forced
element in order to grant a climax
towards the end not like it all happened
at the end likes that started happening
in the latter half it was just it's just
odd but that first half of the book
especially is magical
and after that like I said it doesn't
fall apart by any means but once it
actually starts having a discernible
plot that's moving forward it's it loses
just a little bit of the touch that's
going on there but all that said I do
want to stress I am very happy I read
this for a not dissimilar to reason to
why I'm very happy that I read The Last
Unicorn
although I last Unicron I did enjoy
quite a bit more which is that it's
incredibly well-crafted and what it is
doing and the way in which it is telling
its story is distinct and unlike nearly
anything else that I've ever read and
for that alone I am glad to have read it
but even beyond that I do I did take
enjoyment out of this and just getting
to experience a very different way of
conveying characters and story that left
me again like I said unsure of what had
happened but certain in how I felt about
it that was such a strange reading
experience but it's what I'm really glad
that I had I don't know if anybody
watching has read this but if you have I
would love to hear your thoughts on it
if you haven't if any of what I said
sounded interesting give it a shot just
don't listen to the audiobook so that'll
do it folks little big have you read it
or heard about it or know of anything
similar to it whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to doubt
and to do down there as well because
there's buttons links there's the
patreon I mentioned at the front end
this was a patreon commissioned a book
and if you have something you want me to
watch or read you could do the same
thing or you could support me at any
level it helps it really does but you
don't have to go that far you can like
subscribe share but you also don't have
to do that either cuz at the end of the
day you're the council I'm just runnin
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]